welcome to this video stalker man that's
a new account right never played this
guy Sedaka men from sweden this laughs
let's see Thanks playing a6 chip mining
co line I like this approach many people
nowadays don't go for that anymore them
I couldn't be three as them right now
before that before and many players
nowadays they don't go for B 5 against
the three they go in they go e six or
sometimes sometimes stuff like like g6
like a cam ski for instance is playing
like that why did i confuse confuse the
Lions him huh I wonder
I wonder if I did confuse something but
okay I like it him now be 492 but he's
giving me a pawn right here or not how
does he keep the beef up on hmm that's
weird maybe wants to really sacrifice it
some idea with that ephi if you have
this might might be might be possible
okay I cannot take only five really
that's not a good idea it should be to
Allah c4 hmm now I understand that is
some that is interesting so what what am
I going to do but this is relatively
stable as it is I can flick in this move
maybe hmm if I go there should be two
leaf or night h2 is this sensible that
should be ok really night age to an F on
IG form it's not ideal but oh he's doing
something entirely different huh I
didn't expect that move at all hmm ok so
let's let's get let's get castles
hmm yeah he's got some some some
pressure nevertheless I never really
want to do take down every we really
want to take only five but but this
oh not sure with Queenie for possible
Batman vos has 9220 Bishop of three mmm
not so easy oh come on that's not the
best move i'm pretty sure about it but
let's get rid of this pin and maybe
allow 93 to be played if he is not
taking on e2 i will go 93
yeah I still have the pawn it's as
simple as that what no I can already
believe in that move g5 out of the blue
what was the point of it that's it's
really a very very straightforward way
to play okay so g4 he wants to chick
make me on edge to this is the the whole
point of it okay can think about taking
only five maybe do that I mean he's
opening his position really quite quite
a lot so
hmm okay
yeah that's dangerous I mean okay I'm
and I've have spent tons of time as
usual trying to activate the snide very
very questionable that this was very
much certainly not the best best way to
play but I had to to play some move team
at King looks fairly safe at least I
mean you can debate if his King is any
any safer that same night only four is a
real nuisance very a very strong piece
time morning
I believe it will that will get tricky
maybe can even play Knight be three
that's kind of weird move now night see
one wow yeah that is what happens if you
okay he didn't didn't really consider
that more night see one was just good of
course winning my guess
now a five is gone
I can actually take another look is good
for 97
97 s threatened now and then sketching
up on the clock okay cannot do this but
I can take h5 and e 60 angling and
angling for checks on f3 and h3 f have
to be alert okay
I could have taken the rook actually I
didn't do that this is hanging as well
check ah what the tricky position
Yeah right 20 seconds what idiotic play
ah chai it's always frustrating
completely one-sided game that i bungled
up on time like what haha well I
completely fell asleep there I was I was
okay at timewise 40 seconds is totally
enough to win with this this is extra
piece I totally didn't didn't didn't
speed up here I did I always liked you
or four seconds this is this is too much
this is too much I mean any move wins
this is a plus seven position Bishop c3
or whatever but twenty eight twenty
second I'm just totally totally too slow
here guarantee it is it's of course
already already a bit a bit a bit tricky
but he could have played 91 this was a
game with with many mistakes g5
assistance of course well no words um
but it had led to had led to practical
problems we should be one probably so is
safe from for f3 yeah well the time it's
always tricky to do with this time
disadvantage that I put myself into and
she it's already a big mess by ambers
night see one was very simple but I
don't know he wanted to blunder peas
instead yeah and he of quasi just have
just have to win yeah I can just I can
also take age 5 or whatever mmm but I
really have to go into pre move mode
that was my problem I just still spent
seconds for each move and this is just
just useless because well it's a
peaceful for pretty much nothing and you
should should pre move mostly or just be
quicker this was just lost on the clock
completely in this game
oh ok thanks for watching